I'm the only rational really to be
honest as much as I've predicted and as
much as I've been correct about is there
a reason I am kind of not made a leader
not really not really
I should kind of emerge from this as
kind of a leader that kind of you know
cuz I get it I get both sides
I have friends are cops i friended her
protesters I have friends that are
rubber bullets I have friends that are
batons I have I went to school with a
tear gas canister who's I still talk to
all the time I have friends that are
looters I have friends that are shards
of glass I have friends that are deep
state CIA agitators I have friends that
are uh you know people that work for
Chinese intelligence Russian
intelligence okay I have friends that
are targets I get everywhere everybody's
coming from I can understand it
I have friends that are counterfeit
bills and I have friends that are cops
that are murderers so all across the
board I just think we can't live in a
world of unfocused rage you know cops
need to be taken down several pegs but I
don't see how smashing up a small
business owned by somebody who worked
hard and has never done anything like
everything all the cops just protect
property yeah but freedom is owning
property freedom's the ability to not
have to depend on the government
freedoms the ability to do something
without the approval of a [ __ ]
nameless faceless group of bureaucrats
you know so okay you know what cops
would protect property can we have guns
to protect property no well then who's
what we shouldn't have private property
well then what are we gonna do well the
government should just dole out the land
and as they see fit to who who's the
government who's this magical government
that is somehow going to do this
appropriately you mean the same
government that backs the police so you
want them handing out the land and you
want them sticking a needle in your ass
in Walgreens you are Billa Melinda Gates
putting a needle in your ass
and you want the government deciding
where you live and how you live and you
want and and and but ha try to follow
logically where what this is for I don't
get it I'm confused and don't come like
I don't read any of the comments but
like while you're typing a 7 paragraph
response to me right now about why
private property is just a tool of white
supremacy realize no one's reading it
truly realize no one's reading it what
are those 12 thumbs up gonna do for you
go get a rubber bullet to the face if
you believe in that why aren't you go
and blow yourself up I mean that's the
thing in this country we got a bunch of
[ __ ] you know here's the thing about
the Middle East they don't have a
problem with putting the vest on now I
am NOT saying to put I am not saying to
put the vest on and I don't mean the
bulletproof vest ok and I'm not saying
to put the vest on but let's be very
clear let's be very clear about don't
there's a difference
ain't nobody nan tha's got the vest on
you know what I mean in the budding
anthems got the vest on I'm not saying
to go out there wear a suicide vest you
know my sponsors would probably be angry
but Chris Hedges quote great the idea
that an tyfa which on the spectrum of
terrorist groups would rank alongside
the Boy Scouts is behind these clashes
is as ridiculous as the idea that Russia
is responsible fuel action of trauma
this desperate search for explanations
that absolve the ruling elites so a
Susan Rice it was Obama's not SAC
national security adviser blamed the
violence on foreign actors heading this
is right out of the Russia playbook by
the way there will never be a problem in
this country that it's not blamed on
Russia or covet 19
it'll be Russia and covet 19 are working
together Russia and Chinese bats are
working together Russian BOTS and
Chinese bats it's Russian BOTS and
chinese bats Russian BOTS and Chinese
bats sorry we shot you in the face - did
you have a boot on your neck it's a
chance a Chinese bot it's a Chinese bad
or Russian bot it wasn't a boot on your
neck
did your husk it foreclosed on it's a
Chinese fat bat bot bot that that's what
it is just the government she's sitting
there on a pedophile island being like
soon they'll do that and just a lot of
Russian actors here on little st. James
there's just Russians and all the beds
Russians running around and Jeffrey
Epstein was a Russian less wexter was a
Russian they're all Russian they died of
Cove in nineteen everything coma 19 is
rochet efforts of Russia's got a coma 19
it's Chinese pot it's not even real -
Russian pot Chinese bad it's a
coronaviruses a bad flu high fatality
rates a ventilator we need a ventilator
it's Russia China